wir kommen zu unserem letzten fall und
der hat was zu tun mit wirklich einer
tollen aktion die wir zusammen mit tui
gestartet haben wie belohnen corona
helden mit gratis urlaub und clemens
übler aus nürnberg hat uns auch ein
video geschickt und wir wollen noch mal
darüber sprechen
harry bleibt sie arbeiten im
rettungsdienst sind wirklich
wahrscheinlich tag und nacht im einsatz
müssen schichtdienst machen
warum sind sie ein corona hält ja hallo
erstmal also ich habe durch gewalt diese
aktion leben mitbekommen von tui und
bild und war gleich begeistert weil ich
meine frau eigentlich bringen hat
vorgeschlagen habe weil meine frau ein
paar zusatzfunktionen also dieses nutzer
sanitären auch bei mir auf der
rettungswache habe ich sie kennengelernt
und die hat viele zusatzfunktionen was
so hygiene betrifft was da natürlich in
der korona zeit ein großes thema war und
deswegen war sie für mich so der korona
hält deswegen hab ich sie vorgeschlagen
aber zehn tagen aus ihrem alltag sie
machen also schichtdienst sie müssen
sich an verschiedene regeln halten
schichtdienst ist ja auch nicht so
einfach wochenendarbeit möglicherweise
haben sie da jetzt überstunden an golf
oder können sie die jetzt einigermaßen
bequem abbummeln nee also ab zumindest
uns gar nicht drin
überstunden ist immer eigentlich jeden
tag drin hat sich im keinen der wirklich
seine schicht beendet
also wir haben 30 26 14 14 22 und 22 6
uhr und gerade die nachtschichten die
zellen dann natürlich schon an den
nerven gerade jetzt in der korona zeit
in konnte nicht in die kita wir haben
bei jährigen tochter mit unserem
rettungsdienstleiter konnten wir dank
abstimmen dass der eine meistens
frühschicht werte andere dann halt
nachtschicht oder spätschicht dass man
sich sozusagen die tochter übergeben
konnte und den haushalt man hat zwar
dann im privatleben nicht so viel
miteinander zu tun was halt schwierig
ist aber das können wir glaube ich ganz
gut wegstecken
wir ergänzen oder uns da ganz gut das
sind wirklich gute nachrichten wie ist
das jetzt also sie passen jetzt auf ihre
tochter auf und ihre frau arbeitet
wahrscheinlich oder also ich habe ich
habe heute dienstag von 6 bis 14 uhr
können uns nach hause gekommen man nicht
eindeutig
16.10 uhr schicht auf dem rettungswagen
und wir arbeiten so dieses eineinhalb
stunden zeitfenster ca wo wir dann uns
den haushalt den rund die tochter
natürlich übergeben und ja nicht raus
jetzt gar doch die woche gegangen zum
arbeiten und ich habe jetzt die kleine
daheim
na ja wir haben uns über ihren fall
unterhalten wir fanden ihre bewerbung
wirklich sehr gut und ich kann ihnen
sagen dann entschieden sie bekommen
gratis urlaub nicht wirklich doch wir
überraschen sie ziehe mit der nachricht
sie bekommen auch gratis urlaub und
konnte sich gleich ein bisschen tränen
in den augen fielen dank zwei jahren
nicht mehr im urlaub dann trifft es
absolut die richtige
dann müssen sie unbedingt ihre frau
anrufen und wir können ihnen ihren
urlaub sie können sich auch bis mitte
nächsten jahres entscheiden wo sie
hinfahren mit tui tui hat er
verschiedene ziele angeboten werden mit
ihm kontakt auf und das sozusagen so
sehen glückliche gewinner aus
toll ich freue mich mit ihnen danke wo
wollen sie hin fast schon ein
lieblingsziel post das wäre unsere
dominsel weil da haben wir unsere
flitterwochen
dann müssen wir das irgendwie möglich
machen also wäre für alles offen also
schenken gaul schaut man nicht ins maul
sagt mein mann wollte aber sie freuen
sich wirklich und das macht mich auch
glücklich ich bin wirklich also wir wir
sind beide hart am arbeiten und schon an
der belastungsgrenze kommt zur guten
zeit gut dann ist uns diese überraschung
auch gelungen an can dance absolut der
richtige gewinner oder ich bin schon und
vor allen dingen ich habe besonders
irgendwie ja wir besonders gepackt hier
auch in der jury entscheidung dass da
irgendwie 2 zusammen jetzt urlaub wieder
machen können die sicherheit im moment
gar nicht sehen können weil sie
irgendwie schichtdienst arbeiten so
aneinander vorbei arbeiten und endlich
wieder sozusagen im urlaub
zusammenfinden und das finde ich toll
und die drehen ist immer noch nicht
sogar das gilt mit
also herr hippler ich wünsche ihnen
schöne urlaub wird bleiben in kontakt
dass sie auch wirklich tolle tage mit
bild und tui verbringen können
damit ist die sendung beendet wieder
ganz ein
oder ist doch dass die tochter default
sich auch